well opportunity for any classification
with
Thank You Nico first of all I want to
start by thanking the organizers Mona
Nicole Steven rock is based on joint
work with Katrina we get Aaron watt
Bognor and Steven whoo
I would like to start with very simple
to start with a very simple online
classification setting so this guy's a
weatherman here and as a part of his job
requirements he's required to predict
with good accuracy whether it's going to
be sunny or rainy tomorrow so he also
has access to field measurements so the
temperature today or the wind and the
humidity and he has to make a prediction
the next day he finds out if a guy right
or made a mistake you don't want to make
mistakes point is regardless of the
prediction made you have two arrows here
this is why this is because weather
predicted sunny or rainy is going to
find out whether the prediction was
correct or not so the feed becomes
regardless of the prediction whereas the
majority of settings where fairness is a
primary concern are actually partial
feedback are not full feedback so if
we're talking about landing hiring
college admissions recidivism prediction
online advertising predictive policing
medical treatment still hell or they all
have one thing in common this is the
only observed feedback for one of the
predictions so for landing we only
observe feedback for the candidates we
actually approve of a loan for hiring
only once we hire have the ability to
demonstrate that there will be good
employees and the same with college
admissions and each of these settings so
let's just talk about this landing
setting where you have a bank and on
each given day
an individual shows up the bank shows
sees the measurements of this individual
like the income the age or whatever
measurements that might help him to make
the decision and the bank either
approves or denies this individual of
the loan but here we only have one arrow
because we don't see feedback for people
who are denied of the loan so this is
partial feeder
and the consequence is that decisions
not only affect accurate how accurate we
are but also the amount and type of data
we collect so the decisions we make
along the way also affect our ability to
learn what are the best policies in the
later phases of the process and the
Stano techniques on gather data might
lead if we're not careful to feedback
loops and risk being highly unfair so
I'll give one example of that in the
form of the pratfall system that's
currently in use in about 60 police
departments across the US and one of the
main concerns was that if you start with
neighborhoods that have different crime
rates Fred Paul is going to suggest that
you dispatch more troops to
neighborhoods that start with a higher
crime rate and as you do that they're
going to naturally detect more crimes
and then in the next stage the loop is
going to reinforce itself so you have a
self-fulfilling prophecy and this is
just an article from the news academics
confirmed that major predictive policing
algorithm is fundamentally flawed and
the model that they use in this
algorithm the core of it is based on
earth earthquake prediction so you have
the small words like if you have an
earthquake happening in some region
naturally you have a higher probability
of this recurring or happening again and
this is what Christian loam had to say
about the Fred Paul study 2016 the key
point of the proposed study is that
virtually all predictive policing models
use crime data from police departments
but Police Department data is not
representative of all crimes committed
police aren't notified about all crimes
that happened they don't document all
crimes they respond to police recorded
data is a combination of policing
strategy police community relations and
criminality if a police department has a
history of over policing some
communities over others predictive
policing predictive policing will merely
reproduce these patterns in subsequent
predictions this is the exact concern
here so formally our problem setting is
online Costa fication
with one-sided feedback not full
feedback so let's go back to the example
of landing and this banker this bank has
three possible own policies denoted here
by blue orange and green on every round
the bank has to commit to one of these
lending policies and let's say this R on
the bank selects to commit to the blue
policy and then on each day an
individual shows up and this individual
is either approved or denied of the loan
according to the policy the bank has
committed to so the bank is the policy
the bank has committed to is binding for
any individual that might show up and
this is important next up the prediction
is varied according to the individual
and the policy individual is either
approved or denied and we see only
feedback if the individual is actually
approved of the law so a natural measure
of how well the bank did at the end of
this process let's say they grants for
some number of days the bank might ask
how well do compared to the best
available policy let's say it ones for
five days and this is the sequence of
selections by the bank and the best
policy is the green one and the bank
might compare his performance to the
performance that would have been
achieved by the best one so this is just
a usual notion of regret this is H star
here is the optimal policy in our case
the green policy and this is just the
loss they expected loss over t rounds of
this optimal policy what we have here is
just subtracting the the cost or the the
loss incurred by the bank by playing HT
here is any of the policies that the
bank played in the sequence comparing to
the loss would the good would have been
achieved by just playing sticking to the
green policy so the talk is going to be
the outline as W is going to be the
following first I'm going to talk about
low regret with one-sided feedback
next I'm going to talk about the
fairness definitions that we have and
how we incorporate that and and and then
I'm going to combine the two fairness
and one-sided feedback I'm going to
suggest an algorithm and a lower back
matching lower bound so let's start with
low regretted one-sided feedback so the
warm-up question can be even guaranteed
low regret despite only seeing one-sided
feedback so how can we expect to
guarantee low regret if the learner
can't even measure its own regret right
if you make negative decisions if you
deny people off loans
you don't even get to see if this
individual pays we don't have a good
measure of your own regret so looking at
just like the very simple basic 0 1 loss
we can see that in the second row
individuals already denied we cannot
observe what's in the second row is
circled by red so each individual that
we deny off the loan
we actually don't observe that so how do
we go around this difficulty we just add
a vector of once the second column of
this matrix then what we get is that for
the second row we get constant pay off
so regardless of the decision that was
made and regardless of so so regardless
of whether this individual repays or
default if this individual was denied
the payoff is going to always be 1 the
loss is always be 1 it's a constant loss
so what we actually get by that is that
we can easily cast this problem from
one-sided feedback to a contextual
bandage problem so remember contextual
bandits we have finite number of actions
in this case two actions approve or deny
off loans and we have the context that
in this in this case are individuals and
the policy class that we want to compare
with these mappings between contexts and
actions so in this case we have the
purple line here for people who are
approved and then for people we approve
of a loan
we either 0o - if these individual
repairs or default and here in the gold
line this is the second action people we
deny we constantly pay one so in this
case we don't really even observe this
line but since this line is constant
whenever we deny somebody or don't we
know what's going to be the payoff so we
actually have this bandit setting where
we observe any of the lines or each of
the lines according to the prediction
that we make where it's useful because
we have good algorithms for contextual
bandits okay we can by casting this
problem is contextual bandit we can use
this algorithm okay so we did this
transformation on the lost matrix so one
question is why can we even do this
transformation that doesn't do the
factory direct guarantees that we are
going to get so important an important
observation is that the lost matrix is
regret preserving so if we look at the
transformed loss matrix and we look at a
stream of individuals over time so the
loss of any hypothesis here that was
formed loss if you measure it is just
the original loss which is the term here
under the original 0 1 loss matrix plus
this additional term in this additional
term is just the number of red rounds
here so red rounds are individuals that
default so these are the bad candidates
so any round at the bandwidth that a bad
candidate shows up regardless of the
made decision we pay one more because
this is 2 & 1 instead of 1 & 0 so the
takeaway is that for any hypothesis
regardless of the predictions made we
have just like an additional term that
depends on the number of bad candidates
showing up in the stream so regret does
not change if you compare two hypothesis
even after you do this transformation
as a conclusion given a contextual
bandit algorithm that guarantees some
regret regret t we can translate it to a
one-sided or one-sided feedback
algorithm that guarantees twice the
regret and the two factor just comes
from the rescaling of the loss not sure
it's the same regret that you're
measuring you have the same regret
against the policy that you measure
because it assumes zero regret for any
to do not manage the situation no it
does not sooner
okay it's the same regret that you're
measuring against that policy I think it
was like a question in the payoff matrix
like the cemetry right yeah like if you
reject someone you should give it alone
you always get you always pay your way
okay so the bottom line is that you can
get the same regret after - up to this
constant factor here okay the next
question is when we look at the setting
that we have now next what about
fairness
so we have this online setting with
partial feedback and on each day the
bank deploys a loan policy here denoted
by HT natural requirement would would be
that this loan policy that is binding
for any individual that shows up would
be a fair policy so in order for talking
about fairness we have to first define
the measure of fairness that we're
working with so first of all just a
technical note we allow deploying a
distribution of a hypothesis and not
just a single hypothesis this will be
helpful to get better trade-offs with
accuracy in fairness and the definition
of fairness that we will use is a false
positive rate or the false negative rate
here is just like the usual definition
but we also have probability over the
selected hypothesis from the
distribution of hypothesis pi that we
deploy at every round and the second
term is just the difference of the false
positive rates of this policy on the two
different groups in the population
denoted by one or minus one
this addition is that we say an
algorithm is gamma fair if on every
round the difference of the false
positive rate of this policy that we
deploy is more or equal to GAAP
now is the first example for that let's
say that we have a positive class with
five different hypotheses these two
cause a negative just for accepting
everyone or denying every one of the
loan just constant policies they have a
zero false positive difference because
you either accept everybody or deny
everybody and let's say that we have h1
h2 and h3
so the feasible regime is this blue
shape here and these are the trade-offs
that you can get but if you also want to
be gamma fair it's just this green area
and if you do not allow randomization
the best one that you can choose is
actually h2 here you get you the best
trader if you also allow to randomize
over hypothesis you can get to this
optimal point and and an observation
that is useful in our paper is that the
optimal gamma fare policy is always of
support sides at most two combination of
h1 + H+ rate is on the underlying
distribution so you want the policy that
you deploy on each round to be
so it's it's it's so it's defined over
on expectation on the underlying
distribution not the position but I
guess those kind of quantities will
concentrate around each other
so going back here the optimal point is
why would you use each policy but each
one guarantees individually that the
difference in positive resistance yes so
each policy that you use you can use
different policies but each one has this
guarantee on the other line distribution
over here so you will be getting one
sided feedback yeah can you measure the
false positive rate this is so this is a
good question this is a good question
and address it in the following slide
yes all right so the question that we
ask is what is the trade-off between
fairness and regret in the partial
feedback setting well specifically if we
constraint our policy to be gamma fair
on every round what is the regret
guarantee that we can give so this is
the third section and I'm going to talk
about the algorithm that we propose for
the fairness and one-sided feedback side
so this is the main result of our paper
and the main result is that there exists
an algorithm that runs in polynomial
time given access to an optimization
Oracle talked about this in the
following slide over H and guarantees
the two guarantees here that the
fairness on any given round is gamma
plus plus T to the minus 1/4 fair on
every round where gamma is just any
constant between 0 and 1 and the regret
is roughly the order of root T log H to
the best gamma fair policy in H
we're on this you have time steps of the
algorithm capital T capital T is a time
horizon this is the total number of
friends so you run for capital T rounds
yes and the pair round regret the pair
unfairness that you have so scales like
this with the minus one like T as an
order of one hundred thousand or ten
thousand this is what you get so with
high probability the policy that we
deploy on every round is going to give
you this amount of fairness on the
underlying distribution
so I'll just mention briefly so this is
the mini-monster algorithm by Agarwal a
tile an algorithm that we use as a
building block for our algorithm for a
fair one side at the feedback setting
this is a an Oracle efficient algorithm
also gives high probability guarantees
for contextual bandits but this
algorithm has no fairness guarantees so
we want to also insert fairness
guarantees to make sure that the policy
we deploy in every round is fair so the
algorithm that we suggest is the
following let's say that here we have
the time okay so first of all for an
order of root T log H rounds the first
arrivals all labeled we all predict them
to be positive to observe the labels
this is just people that show up here
then so d sub e here is the empirical
distribution of measurements and true
labels of these individuals that show up
here and we use the empirical
distribution to little H fair here which
is the policy class so these are only
policies right probability distributions
over hypothesis that are empirically
gamma fair on the observed distribution
okay and we instantiate the mini-monster
algorithm according so with this
hypothesis class with H fair so
mini-monster algorithm is going to
always play a fair policy and is going
to guarantee as they regret guarantees
that we're in the former slide on these
people so one observation to make is
that we don't really explicitly build
this subset of the policy class so this
is where the optimization worker that I
mentioned earlier enters the picture so
here mini-monster is the Oracle
efficient algorithm and the Oracle
that we are going to construct is going
to be a fair cost-sensitive
classification or so I think Aaron
mentioned this earlier but
cost-sensitive classification problem is
just you have a set of points costs for
predicting positive negative and you
want to minimize the total cost and it's
equivalent to weighted binary
classification so what we use in the
paper is we actually rely on having an
access to this CSC or ago and on top of
that we build a fair cost-sensitive
classification so the theorem is the
following given a new here which is the
approximation there exist an Oracle
efficient algorithm that calls the
original Oracle for at most one over the
approximation terms where number of
times and outputs affair a gamma fair
distribution such that the cost
according to the randomness in the
policy so that the cost is the optimal
cost plus some approximation to and this
the proof of this is just adopted with
from the Agarwal at all this is a paper
called the reductions approach to Africa
fication with some technical changes
I'll mention in the next slide so the
access here is just
mini-monster this contextual bandit
algorithm accesses has access to the h
fare to the class of fair policies on
the empirical data through calls to the
fair cost-sensitive classification
Oracle so it does it in an efficient way
so in the paper we also adapt the
cost-sensitive classification Oracle to
the fair version in the case where the
furnace constraint is only defined on
the subset of points considered in the
cost objective so going back to your
question we only use a subset because we
can only measure the false positive rate
on the first and on people who show up
in the exploration phase
because we cannot measure the false
positive rate on people in the second
phase so if your definition of fairness
was the false discovery rate with that T
to the minus 1/4 term go away you mean
you did to defaulted principal where the
fraction of people who you released
negative rate well depending on which
you call positive so the answer is that
the algorithm so if we switch the
definitions to false negative rate or
statistical parity the algorithm would
just work the same different definitions
of fairness this is something that is
not yet guaranteed and we might want to
explore as a next step
and the second difference so the regret
analysis for the fair vision of the
mini-monster algorithm we also have to
take into account and the digital
approximation error so we have this
approximation error because we construct
the fair cost-sensitive classification
or Co and because we have a problem with
false positive rate constraints in order
to maintain those constraints we induce
another approximation error for the
objective so we also have to take this
into account when we analyze the regret
of the mini-monster algorithm ok next up
the lower bound so the claim is the
following there exists a hypothesis
class H such that any algorithm that is
T to the minus alpha fair must have
expected regret which is the order of T
to the 2 times alpha so this is a
matching lower bound to the upper
boundary we just stated if you pick
alpha to be one to one water so any
algorithm that is T to the minus 1 water
fair the regrets scales as log t as root
T sorry and what's the what's the idea
of this lower bound we defined two
similar distributions D 1 and D 2 small
KL divergence between the two and it's
able to distinguish the two
distributions and algorithm has to act
very conservatively otherwise the
algorithm risks being unfair by acting
conservatively on the first rounds on
each of these rounds the algorithm
incurs high regret so this is the
construction let's say we have these two
add these two distributions new 1 and D
2 and let's say this is these are the
available hypotheses here so this is
predicting positive on everyone because
when we assume that the base rate is 1/2
so they're both on the same point here
and we have two other hypotheses one of
them is the optimal one and the optimal
hypothesis on the first distribution is
this h2 completely fair whereas the
other hypothesis h1 is unfair because it
falls outside the gamma fare regime but
it's it's four times gamma here
so in order to find the best hypothesis
which is either h2 or h1 in this case
since the algorithm is gamma fair on
every round so in the first case where
we have d1 an algorithm can only play
can only deploy h1 here with
probabilities smaller or equal to 1/4
otherwise it is unfair and the same with
h2 on the distribution the second
distribution in this case next as a
corollary of Pinsker inequality for this
many rounds for the order of like at
least fade over gamma squared rounds you
cannot distinguish the probability that
you play any hypothesis on the two
distributions by more than beta so the
probability that you play h1 on d2 is
the same as the probability of playing
h1 on d1 with a difference of at most
beta so in both of these cases that take
away is that the probability that you
play either h1 or h2 in both of these
cases is at most 1/2 plus beta so you're
going to play with probability close to
1/2 one of these two hypotheses positive
or negative
which are very suboptimal so for each of
these rounds that you have here you're
going to suffer linear regret and it's
reset gamma to be T to the minus 1/4 you
get that that for T to the minus 1/4
fairness at least the regret has to be
at least T to the 2 times at root T to
the best fair policy
on the last slide anything special about
having four gamma over there it seems
like it could be any arm charlie large
oh no there's nothing there's nothing
special about this this is just one
selection it doesn't have to be four
times gamma but it seems like you could
get an arbitrarily large number of times
gamma which means that you can't play h1
or h2 with so in the formal statement I
don't think it's arbitrarily large so in
the formal statement you also have like
we have a high probability statement
that also enters the picture but maybe
it's not arbitrarily large but the
constant times gamma it's what you can
on the last slide
yeah whether it's an arbitrarily large
constant so that this four is affecting
the ability to play so you cannot play
with just the probability 140 right and
if you make it arbitrarily large yes yes
but I guess like any constant that you
put it any constant would would maybe
work but then a constant I don't think a
variance would be
okay so like two two points that before
I end my talk is so to open problems
that come from the paper is what we have
both false positive and false negative
constraints so if we want to enforce
playing a policy deploying the policy
that gives us gamma false positive and
gamma false negative at the same time
how do we get that and this is not so
simple it turns out that we don't really
have an efficient or like way of doing
that and achieving low regret and it has
to do with the structure of the
hypothesis class so if you want to
optimize over one constraint you can
always use a hypothesis that is
predicting according to the protected
bit in the other direction and sort of
on average get rid of discrimination
without paying a lot of regret this is
something that we don't really know how
to do efficiently when you have two
constraints another question is what
happens with other definitions of
fairness
so I mentioned it works also for
statistical parity but other definitions
we might think what happens with
calibration for example other
definitions of fairness it's not yet
clear what are the trade-offs that we
can get
[Applause]
yes so it's a very common practical
scenario so every landing or every
hiring scenario or every so medical
trials for example the only if you
administer the treatment you find out if
it's a successful and unsuccessful one
only people that you'll earn money to
are the ones that you can see if they
repair your default yeah but you cannot
do it in every case though like if you
talk about medical trial so if you talk
about predictive policing so yeah
lending yes because lending exploration
is also the outcome the outcome that
comes from exploring on an individual is
a positive outcome because you know you
give a loan but if you try a new
treatment Oh like with recidivism if you
just let people randomly go at the
beginning that's very problematic you
can't
in some context that's perfectly
acceptable in some other context we
might want to consider what's at stake
did you about questions
I thought I saw you raise your great
[Applause]